FOR "BULLS AND BEARS" AND ON
SUNDAY.
BRYAN'S NEXT.
>> GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
TUCKER TONIGHT.
I'LL FILL IN FOR TUCKER FOR THE
HOUR.
>> APPARENTLY, E-MAILS CAN RUN
THE ONLY ONE IN HER FAMILY
HER EX-HUSBAND'S LAPTOP.
ED HENRY IS HERE WITH ALL NEW
E-MAIL DEVELOPMENTS.
HEY, ED.
>> BRYAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
ABOUT NEEN
ABINT NEEN
ABINENNEEN
ABINENE WANTS THE YEAR TO BE
OVER.
THE YEAR ENDED WITH FAMILY
DRAMA.
IN NOVEMBER, HER ESTRANGED
HUSBAND ANTHONY WEINER WAS
CONVICTED OF SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
AN UNDERAGED GERL.
>> ABERDEEN WAS CONVICTED IN A
44-YEAR-OLD FACES A DECADE IN
PRISON AFTER A JURY FOUND HE AND
AN ASSOCIATE GUILTY OF COOKING
THE BOOKS AT KIT DIGITAL.
INTRODUCE FAKE E-MAILS AS
EVIDENCE TO VINDICATE HIM.
THE NEW YORK POST REPORTED THAT
TERRORIST ATTACKS.
JAMES COMEY SUGGESTED HILARY
CLINTON HAD AN E-MAIL PROBLEM ON
THE OCTOBER OF THE EVE OF THE
ELECTION.
SHE'S BEEN VINDICATED.
BRYAN.
SEVERAL HAD CLASSIFIED